>>> THERE'S A NEW FACE IN
DAYTIME.
>> HELLO TO ALL MY BEAUTIFUL
WILD FLOWERS
>> AFTER SEEING WHAT WENT DOWN
WITH ELLEN, WE TOOK A HARD TURN
IN THE OTHER DIRECTION
>> I AM JUST LIKE YOU.
A BOHO FREE SPIRIT MOMMY MOTHER
MOVIE STAR SINCE I WAS 6
>> IT'S "THE DREW BARRYMORE
SHOW."
>> HOW DREW YOU DO
>> TUNE IN TO SEE HER HAVE A
BLAST BY HERSELF IN A BIG EMPTY
STUDIO
>> TOTALLY MOTALLY OTALLY.
>> WATCH AS SHE CONNECTS TO HER
ZOOM AUDIENCE.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING MY VFFs,
VIRTUAL FRIENDS FOREVER.
>> DREW GIVES BACK TO WORTHY
FAMILIES IN THE BEST WAY SHE
CAN.
>> HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP?
>> YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN TOUGH.
MY HUSBAND AND I ARE WORKING
FROM HOME AND WE HAVE ALMOST
$50,000 IN HOSPITAL BILLS.
>> I FEEL THAT, LINDA.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE PAYING TO
RENOVATE YOUR WALK-IN CLOSET
>> AND DON'T WORRY ABOUT HER
BEING MEAN TO THE CREW
>> THANK YOU
>> THEY SAY SHE MAINTAINS EYE
CONTACT TOO LONG AND IS TOO
EMOTIONALLY SUPPORTIVE
>> JUST --
>> I'M A HUGGER.
>> NO.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU
>> BE THE THIRD WHEEL IN A
CELEBRITY CATCH-UP
>> MY BEST FRIEND REESE
WITHERSPOON, THE BEST WOMAN ON
EARTH.
YOU ARE LITERALLY -- I MARVEL AT
YOU.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> I WANT TO COME INTO YOUR ROOM
AND MURDER YOU WITH A BUTTER
SPOON.
>> GET DREW'S TAKE ON THE NEWS
>> HOT OFF THE PRESS, BRUSHING
YOUR TEETH IS A GAME CHANGER
>> AND STAY TUNED FOR A
HARROWING CATCH-UP BETWEEN DREW
AND HER EX-HUSBAND TOM GREEN
>> IT'S BEEN WHAT, 15 YEARS?
>> YEAH.
WOULD YOU LIKE SOME SAUSAGE?
>> YOU WANT GUESTS
DREW TEXTS EVERYONE IN HER PHONE
AND INTERVIEWS WHOEVER SHOWS UP.
LIKE NICOLE KIDMAN
>> THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE ON YOUR SHOW.
>> DREW, THIS IS YOUR SHOW
>> OH, MY GOD.
THANK YOU.
>> AT LEAST SOMEONE'S ENJOYING
>> AND NOW SENSATIONAL
HOMOSEXUAL BILLY PORTER SINGING
TO A FLOWER.
♪ EDELWEISS
♪ OH
♪ AY, AY, AY, AY
>> IS THIS HAPPENING
OR AM I KIND OF HIGH
>> "THE DREW BARRYMORE SHOW.
YOU'RE IN YOUR BED ANYWAY.
JUST WATCH IT.